هنا في مستشفى ثانيه ترمل في مدينه تطوان
في شمال المغرب عادت الابتسامه اخيرا الى
محيا والده ووالد الطفل المغربي الفقيد
ريان مولود جديد ذكر اختارت له العائله
اسم ساجد الاجواء خيرة يعني ممتازه الحمد
لله فرحانين ربي يرزقنا المولود الجديد
ساجد
والحمد لله نرى ضروري ولكن شويه يعني
دائما
في الذكرى السنويه الاولى لم تنسى عائله
اورام ابنها الراحل ريان الذي سقط في بئر
ضيق وعميق قبل سنه في قريه جبليه
بضواحي مدينه شفشاون في شمال المغرب قد
فرحنا كثيرا من هذا من هذا المولد الان
لان
سيعوضني في
ريان يعني ويكون ان شاء الله مولود صالح
ان شاء الله كان من المفترض ان نحيي هذه
الذكرى باستحضار تلك الماساه وتلك
المعاناه والالم والحزن لكن شاءت اقدار
الله تعالى ان يعوض ذكرى صعبه
بفرح بمصارات
بسرور طبعا كما راينا على ملامح والده
ووالد الطفل يعني استبدوا سعاده غامره
فعلا قررت عائله اورام مواصله حيات رغم
ظروفها الاجتماعيه
وانتقلت للعيش في مدينه تطوان بينما
الراحل ريان سيبقى حيا في قلوب العائله
عادل الزبير العربيه مدينه تطوان في شمال
المغرب